JANE GOODALL: My mission was
to get close to the chimpanzees
and live among them,
to be accepted.
When I was 10 and I said, "I'm
going to grow up, go to Africa,
and live with wild animals
and write books about them,"
everybody laughed.
I wanted to do things which
men did and women didn't.
BRETT MORGEN: Jane
grew up in a time
when women did not do
the type of work she did.
And she wasn't going
to be deterred.
JANE GOODALL: Everything
was so different.
I didn't have any
responsibilities except
to learn about the chimpanzees.
Thanks to Brett
Morgen and the way
that he treated this footage,
it took me right back.
BRETT MORGEN: We had 150
hours of disparate shots,
so we hired an army
of people to come in.
And I gave them categories like
mating or eating or sleeping
so we could at
least see everything
grouped in succession
so we could
get a sense of what we had.
JANE GOODALL: And it was
very emotional for me
to just see my life unrolling.
There was more about
my personal life
than there has been in
the other documentaries.
BRETT MORGEN: I decided that it
needed to have a point of view.
And I was going to express that
point of view through music.
To achieve that, I
enlisted this support
and aid of Philip Glass.
And, when Philip
delivered his first cue,
I had tears going down my eyes.
I think he said, I think I might
have fallen in love with Jane.
JANE GOODALL: And it's
come together to be
rather an extraordinary film.
So what I hope is it's going to
bring back into people's minds
a renewed determination
to do their bit to save
what's left of this planet.
[music playing]